as a leader
our responsibility is to make the people
feel
that we have their backs and actually
have their backs um so
there's a sort of a nice anthropological
if you want me to go down this rabbit
hole
there's an anthropological i find it
fascinating there's a nice
anthropological explanation which i
actually uh explained in that book
um which is which raises the question
why do we have leaders
human beings are naturally hierarchical
we self-organize all the time it's got
nothing to do with whether you have
formal hierarchy like in an organization
we we're we're constantly
self-organizing like in a sports team
who's who's the better player we
self-organize we pay we pay deference to
the one who is better you know the
scientist who publishes more or the
nobel laureate all the other scientists
pay deference right um
uh this is not by accident there's a
very good anthropological reason for it
going back uh many years you know human
beings have only been farming for the
past 10 or 12 000 years
but we existed for tens of thousands of
years on the planet before that and we
lived in populations that were about 150
we maxed out at about about 150
which raises a very interesting question
we they lived in austere times
people are hungry um somebody you know
brings back some food to the tribe we
all rush in to eat
um well if you're built like a football
player you can shove your way to the
front of the line right but this is a
bad system because if you punch me in
the face this afternoon i'm probably not
going to wake you and alert you to
tanger tonight
um and so it's just a bad system for
cooperation which is if we leave every
person to themselves
and so we evolved into these
hierarchical animals we're constantly
assessing and judging who's higher in
the pecking order who's the alpha of the
group and when we assess that someone is
alpha to us we naturally step back we
naturally defer and allow our alphas to
eat first
um um and we uh get fed later and i
don't get an elbow in the face right
good system
this has survived to this modern day
there's not a single person on the
planet absolutely zero
who has any moral anger who is offended
by the idea that somebody more senior in
the organization makes a higher salary
or gets a nicer office or a better
parking space
it offends
nobody now we may think they're useless
at their job but the fact that they make
more money than us because they're
higher up in the organization offends
zero
if you're senior and you leave your coat
in the other room someone will go get it
for you if you're junior and you left
your coke near the room you get your own
coat in other words you get treated
differently
and this is why people want to get
promoted because they like the perks
but the perks don't come for free and
that's the point
which is as you make your way up the
hierarchy as you achieve that alpha
status of the tribe there's an
expectation that sure we'll give you
first choice of meat and we'll give you
first choice of mate but
if danger threatens the tribe
you're going to be the one who runs head
first towards that danger first to
protect us which means you might die
first
right that's why we gave you first
choice of mate because you want to keep
your genes in the gene pool we're not
stupid
and and it's when leaders uh shirk that
responsibility that we start to have
moral outrage so for example nobody has
a problem with a ceo making more money
than they do the problem we have
is when you're willing to lay off your
people to protect your salary to protect
your bonus
rather than find other ways to protect
the people
this is what morally offends us we have
we made a deal there's a deep-seated
anthropological deal that we've made
with our alphas that you have to protect
us
you have to and you have to do what it
takes sometimes sometimes putting your
own interests second
um and then and then you can but if
you're willing to do that
we're proud we're happy you go enjoy
you've earned it
um and so i think this is this is a
large part about building trust which is
it's not just
about saying nice things and being
trustworthy it's that people feel that
you actually have their backs and that
you would be the one to take
responsibility take accountability look
for other ways to protect us if it meant
um we're gonna get hurt